en plein centre-ville de toronto entre
les gratte ciel du monde des affaires
les tours de condos de petits quartiers
résidentiels
les pancartes électorales se font rares
mais au détour d'une ruelle cache un
duel sans merci
deux vedettes deux parties deux
approches bien différente pour gagner la
bataille de l'ontario
le libéral courtise le vol de huit
professionnels qui habitent ces cons 12
les conservateurs progressistes une
pandémie sur la notoriété de la veuve de
jack layton pour reconquérir ce conte
est crucial sur le terrain tous les
partis le concède
les indécis sont nombreux l'ami chemin
de la campagne un élément clé vient de
basculer
les gens commencent à savoir que
monsieur retombe dans les sondages et
tout cela laisse 10 c'est quoi mon vrai
choix
c'est pas juste sortir monsieur rdpc est
ce que j'ai un vrai choix de mourinho
sa vision son plan c'est bien là dessus
que knees le chef libéral pour
poursuivre sa lancée en ontario ces
milliards premier en infrastructures à
l'abri investir dans le logement social
c'est bien plus que de mettre un toit
sur la tête des gens cela crée aussi des
emplois stables bien payés sur lesquels
les familles peuvent compter pour son
candidat
les transports en commun logement
ces milliards permettent de promettre
des changements concrets les dirigeants
al'inverse au npd
le message est simple défaire rappeur
convaincre que thomas mulcair est le
seul capable de l'emporter
le seul qui a eu le courage de tenir
tête à stephen harper pour vraiment
apporter du changement il faut vraiment
avoir le courage de ses convictions nous
démocrates sont en mode attaque tout
pour freiner justin trudeau dans la
province leurs armes
l'appui des libéraux le projet de loi
antiterroriste ses 51 assez pour faire
douter cet électeur et d'ici mais pas
assez pour sceller son vote pour le npd
la campagne est longue les indices
donnent le temps d'y penser
avant d'endosser une vision pour le
changement
emmanuel on le voit clairement deux
stratégies différentes qui se dessine là
chez les libéraux et chez réunion
démocrate
oui tout ça pour réussir à coaliser le
vote du changement mais russie et je
vous dirai à définir la question de
l'isoloir est ce qu'on appelle chez eux
le npd c'est clair le but c'est que la
question c'est qui peut défaire stephen
harper ont la même les affiches et un
effort aussi dans tout seul à hantise du
pdc de plafonner donc ils veulent
essayer de définir cette course là comme
étant une course à deux contre les
conservateurs du côté des libéraux comme
on le mit conservateur et npd dans le
même panier sur la question du déficit
le fait de définir la question autrement
en disant qu'elle est la meilleure
alternative le meilleur gouvernement en
attente donc deux tactiques des
différentes pour un argovien point tu ça
dépend bien sûr du vote conservateur en
ontario oui il a eu tout un effet de
vases communicants acier ce réel suivez
moi bien sûr pour l'instant le voit
conservateurs ne s'est pas effondré en
ontario il faut mettre les choses en
perspective
l'espoir du parti libéral c'est que si
ça arrivait quand ça va arriver eux
seront en position pour en récolter une
bonne partie et ensuite faire basculer
des votes néo-démocrates au npd
si le contraire
on attaque beaucoup justin trudeau
pourquoi parce que dans tous les comtés
de la ceinture industrielle le nord de
la province
on craint que si les libéraux montereau
lasser les conservateurs qui vont se
faufiler ajoutez à ça qu'on sait pas si
les conservateurs vont réussir à
renverser la tendance
vous voyez est encore bien des scénarios
en jeu cette bataille de long terme et
bien des jours encore bien il démontre
notre jour merci beaucoup emmanuel au
revoir
on